well claims about exposure to toxic
chemicals at the clark county government
center continue to grow
it's a story the i-team first broke
about 50 people sue in the county the
city of las vegas and several companies
the i-team's vanessa murphy live more on
this exclusive interviews she did
vanessa
brian and denise since our story first
aired a few weeks ago the number of
plaintiffs went from 50 to 100
now it's expected to go even higher
these are people who have worked inside
the clark county government center here
and said it's made them sick some of the
plaintiffs
are loved ones of people who have died
it's like living a living a bad dream
nick romano says he suffers from liver
damage thyroid disease and other
illnesses
if i had gone one more year to my next
yearly exam
i may not be here speaking to you right
now
for lisa chavez it was uterine cancer i
was able to be with her
you know every day until she passed we
just sat there and watched her wife away
owen bush lost his wife kim to ovarian
cancer
at just 49 years old what they have in
common
work inside the clark county government
center do you believe that her cancer
is connected to that building yeah now
that
they have their uh you know their
scientists their
medical people that are doing the
research well
yes i do kim passed away in 2013.
lawyers say they've now uncovered a
cancer cluster linked to the building
their research dates back to the early
1900s when the land was used by the
union pacific railroad
according to this newspaper clipping by
1952
a tar pit at the site was a known hazard
the railroad then set fire to the pit
and its waste materials
by the 70s that was covered in dirt the
lawsuit also points to several nearby
spills
numerous documents which followed refer
to contamination
and recommendations for more testing and
cleanup
records reveal the city of las vegas
sold the land to clark county
and in the 90s the government center was
built
chavez says she began having flu-like
symptoms when she first started working
there in 2001
i knew that i felt better when i left
work romano points to a black substance
from a vent which he says he collected
and later turned over to lawyers for
testing that's one reason they say
they've confirmed that employees are
exposed
to toxins in january they filed a
lawsuit against
clark county the city of las vegas and
several companies like monsanto
their goal compensation for alleged
victims
and to get the building shut down as of
february 3rd
there are 115 plaintiffs according to
the legal team
half of them had cancer some of them had
multiple cancers
illnesses in the other half include
kidney disease parkinson's and more
11 are dead romano says he medically
retired in
2019. chavez says she still works there
because she's just a couple of years
from retirement do you have any fear
about speaking since you are still an
employee
yes i did i almost backed out
today i feel like you know god saved me
for a reason or a purpose and if i can
help others
then i want to do that so i
was glad to be able to tell my story of
course she's already gone but if they
can
stop you know
other things from happening
both clark county and the city of las
vegas say they do not comment on pending
litigation a spokesman for the railroad
sent a statement saying
union pacific is reviewing the
complaints made in the suit as we
understand it the chemicals allege
exposure to certain chemical the claims
allege exposure to certain chemicals at
the company's former las vegas rail yard
which was sold to the city of las vegas
many years ago
prior to the sale union pacific
performed environmental work
under the direction of the nevada
department of environmental
quality we also reached out to the other
defendants in this case and did not
receive responses
in time for this report we have more
information at 8newsnow.com reporting
live vanessa murphy
8 news now